it's it's interesting to look at these
things from obviously for multiple
perspectives which is another thing that
II alongs don't do right because for
them everything is one cause there's one
that's how you can tell when you're
dealing with someone who's ideological
II possessed is they make everything
attributable to a single cause like
power so but so one of the things that's
happened with the nuclear family that's
quite interesting too is that parents
are older and they and they have fewer
children so you could imagine that that
hothouse environment in some sense has
been exaggerated for a bunch of reasons
one is well your child is a lot more
valuable to you if you're older and you
only have one or two right because
you're not gonna get another chance
that's first of all you might have had
some trouble having the child to begin
with and you're not gonna get another
chance so you've got all your eggs are
in one basket so to speak and then of
course children don't have the number of
siblings they used to have and one of
the things that's really useful about
having siblings is that they keep you in
your place right they their primary
socialization agents and I mean that can
be brutal and that's reflected say in
the story of Cain and Abel you know that
that internal household dynamic with
siblings can be can really become
murderous and that has to be kept under
control but I think the the hothouse
flower person who's who's incapable of
tolerating any jobs or any or any
testing any dominance hierarchy testing
of the sort that you said that men do
part of that's the consequence of being
raised by older parents who have excess
resources who have no siblings because
the child is then of course special and
that specialness well there seems to be
an inverse relationship between that
specialness that's protected and the
person's robustness and resilience and
so and then that's caught into or not
caught into that's that's pandered to by
the universities which insist upon
setting up a situation where no one is
ever offended by anything any of the
time and that's something I also can't
understand at all because that's a huge
point you just made okay because it's
the upper-middle class of the
professional class okay
who postpones having the children okay
because then they go to law school they
go to medical school and they
they have the children after they're
settled okay in a job okay so they're
the ones okay whoever injected this this
this hypersensitive bourgeois ID you
know code into the universities now my
parents were twenty when they married in
21 when they had me okay it might my
father was uh you know went to college
on the GI Bill getting out of out of
World War two so I when I was born my
father was still in college and was
sweeping floors and so on I am the
product of young parents and nature
wants actually younger parents right
because because pregnancy is quicker
it's safer okay and so on and my parents
had the energy okay to you know they're
this useful energy that can-do spirit
that came out of World War two and so on
I'm positive that then then not only
other sibling it was born 14 years later
okay my father this point was a college
professor right so she had completely
different parents than than I did so she
has very excellent manners and so I
she's completely different okay right
and I have all this like when the energy
of me and my parents were just a lot of
their teens I mean but not today we have
this situation no and it's considered
heresy to raise this issue okay that you
have have young women are told okay
there's one future for you you are a
future leader okay you must you must
move forward okay four years of college
and in a person is a professional class
it's not alright so it may be the women
young women's bodies are signaling okay
that they want to be another's maybe
maybe there are signals coming from the
body right of maybe now one thing on
this this this this system of education
that was devised for men okay
there's being funneled along channel
Long's mechanism alright so young women
you know feel unhappy they don't know
why they feel they have no sense of
identity yeah if they if they if they
want to marry and drop out of college
and have it have a baby they would be
treated as traitors to their class what
you are future leader what have a baby
only working-class women would do that
okay the way I find working-class women
okay in general okay far more rounded as
personalities okay they express
themselves forcefully they have body
language that takes up space okay
man says something to them on the street
they are right back in their face and so
on
it is the bourgeois girls okay who are
talked to they're there because they are
special okay we have to postpone actual
life okay from for all these years they
see these these are the girls who are
who misjudged the fraternity parties
setting these are the girls who like
running for parental protection and
hand-holding on the on the committee
investigating what we run on their date
and so on so forth so yes oh yes I think
they want you that you have located of
it that's very interesting the idea that
these these young girls okay who are so
sensitive okay in college so unable to
handle their sex life are the product of
older parents because they went through
the professional career track